the suicide squad this is a big movie a
big movie
uh that you're going to be in and it is
very secretive you are sworn to secrecy
you can't tell anybody about the movie
yes i was told nothing about it they
told me the name of my character so i
just started google it's javelin
javelin yeah we have a picture here of
javelin oh great
and um this is javelin right here oh
smokey jones no okay and uh
now javelin is this is am i correct
i don't know what his superpower is but
like all heroes he must have a special
ability
javelin what can you do can you tell us
anything about him yeah yeah he is a
former german olympic
uh javelin thrower he's very much
athletic he likes to be
rude and evil and he has a very huge
javelin yeah so in this part
you you're required to throw a javelin
i'm guessing or use a javelin i was not
certain what i was supposed to be doing
as this traveling person so i just
started googling all of the things of
javelin
there's a band called javelin so it's
like listening to the music of javelin
that guess what that feels unnecessary
oh i don't know you know potato patootie
and
i also i started a coding in javascript
just for fun i made a website
again it has a form again i wish you had
spoken to the director he probably could
have saved you some time
why why ask just do you know okay did
you travel to
java did you go to java no but i googled
photos of it
okay i also uh wrapped myself in javelin
which sounds like javelin and it's an
oil so i thought why not let's do it and
then also a javelina is an animal it's a
small or medium sized mammal
that is also known as the skunk pig so i
i i visited two of those and we spent
some time together
okay did you ever do anything physical
to prepare for this role
two the skunk pigs no no no what i meant
was
did you ever practice with an actual
javelin because i would imagine that if
the character's name is javelin you
maybe have a javelin yeah but jeff oh
sorry there's a flizzy uh
there's a javelin's off travelling
there's a fly right
i got it i'm pretty sure i got it no
he's here oh you got him
okay all right oh my thing is open great
theater you have here flanagan
what a wonderful place sorry my
interceptor was exposed
okay settle down yeah i'm curious did
you ever
practice with an actual javelin to
prepare for the role of javelin no it's
called acting
[Laughter]
well uh clearly you know very little bit
about the movie and you've shot the film
oh it's short yes but i've forgotten
everything you know it's if you've seen
that film with tommy tommy johnson
and he's like hey everyone what happened
oh look at my pen poop
man in black yes i got one of your
references yeah
that's a popular movie that people have
seen is it true
[Laughter]
i don't know i do want to thank you
because
um a very fond memory all of us remember
where we were
when the pandemic hit when the shutdown
happened
i think i could be wrong i think you
were one of my last
guests before the lights went out and we
all went into that
14-15 month quarantine absolutely conan
when it happened we had our show and
then i felt like that german
character from uh star wars hans uh hans
it's han solo whatever and like he's
like hanging out with jobberman and he's
like bye
oh and he gets frozen in carbonite yeah
and the carbon boy
and then after some months unfreeze and
now this is my first time speaking to
humans again conan
yeah so i'm like conan yeah what
conan what did i say you put an umlaut
over the you go
cunanan cunha no it's just conan conan
sounds cool though well that's your
opinion
why'd you wear a bandana well i just did
it today i
i wanted to i don't know break it up a
little bit
and as you know we wear masks but here
in the theater i like to have like a
bandana and then
what i can do is i can just pull it up
and then look at me
yeah i'm a sassy bandit and so i've been
wearing
uh this today and i just thought it
breaks it up it's a little bit of
color to have a neckerchief i like it i
like it hey where is the nearest saloon
because i'm a cowboy yeah
listen okay i enjoy you very much flula
also i love you as well
uh i didn't say love i said i enjoy you
i also have enjoyments of time
spent with yeah okay um
you're a good guy and uh i want to say
thank you
in your own native tongue maybe you
could tell me how to say that
and what's dunkin shane dunker shirt oh
well that's a song by freddie mercury
it's like in vegas singing it all the
time
i don't think that's freddie mercury
donkey shane yeah my darling
oh wait wait wayne newton wayne newton
wayne hello andy
hi lula how are you oh yeah it's so
great to see you how are you doing
i'm doing fine thank you wonderful and
great to see you as well
oh good yes thank you you look good in
animal prints
thank you very much this is a javelina
print so
oh yeah call back do something physical
you skinned them yeah um i know that uh
as we go out to commercial you probably
and i plug your project you probably
want to do some kind of uh uh german
folk dance on the way out that's
probably something you would prefer to
do i would like this yes yeah
so why don't i begin the suicide squad
is in theaters
and on uh that's that's there's no way
that's
this part was not a german folk dance
you begin the introduction saying i'm
one of the sexiest north bavarian uh uh
male german dj's hello how do you think
it could you don't just wake up and do
it
yeah you make it okay go ahead the
suicide squad is in theaters
and on hbo max august 6th uh
love love it just everything you're
doing everything you're bringing
i love lula borg everybody conan o'brien
everyone
yeah i like it's like us